Australia's fashion industry is having
to take a good long look at itself at
least Queen Tobias for major
international retailers have been in
Sydney for Australian Fashion Week the
local market increasingly crowded and
discretionary spending tight some
Australian designers are coming to rely
increasingly on foreign markets to keep
going exporting is kind of becoming -
about 50% of the business now a year ago
was 0% at the same time Australian
designers and retailers are competing
with new heavyweight competition on home
turf they're competing against the
international high street so stores like
Zara and H&M coming in who are able to
translate runway looks for consumers at
an affordable price point they haven't
had to compete with that before huge
crowds turned up for the opening of H&M
earlier this month in Melbourne 15,000
shoppers crammed the European clothing
giant's first Australian store in queues
persisted for a further two days it was
a site to chill the bones of Australia's
established retailers the northern
hemisphere is invading the southern
hemisphere we've got increased
competition from Topshop increased
competition from Zara H&M other
retailers from the northern hemisphere
rumored to be coming we've got the
online threat from some of the imaging
major American retailers and in a
situation like that a small retailer in
Australia needs to get scale in order to
compete effectively David Jones
announced a well received takeover bid
from South Africa's Woolworths group
this week the tie-up will create one of
the largest retail groups in the
southern hemisphere giving this 176 year
old Australian icon the ability to
better compete with these interlopers